hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
we've been inundated with horror titles
this year some use jump scares some
build an earring environment and some
letters survivor zombie [ __ ] with
friends
that's where Friday the 13th jokes in
machete in hand with something a little
bit different for you just in case you
haven't watched any Friday the 13th
films let me set the scene Jason
Voorhees is the gentleman behind the
mask who is wreaking havoc on Crystal
Lake which happens to be the place
he drowned as a child if you're after a
feel-good story with rainbows and
butterflies then it's probably best to
turn off now things are going to get
dark and a little bit grotesque end
again you either play the part of Jason
plotting to demise the hapless youth
counselors who are currently staying at
the lakes cabin all you players one of
the councils themselves frantically
trying to survive Jason's onslaught of
course there's more to it than that and
if you've ever played the ill-fated
evolved or dead by daylight you already
know the formula well there's a few RPG
elements built into this game for both
Jason and the counselors all wrapped up
in a simple progression system each of
the campers have specific stats which
both hinder and help for example Jenna
Myers has high levels of composure
making it harder for Jess to find her
and the ability also makes it slightly
easier for her to break Jason's grip and
potentially escape all the stats include
stealth strength speed and stamina and
another word intelligence which can be
used to fix vehicles but we'll get to
that in a moment if you watch the Friday
the 13th films your nod Jason has
evolved over the years those differences
are reflected in the game the
quintessential masks from Friday the
13th part 3 is here and also the potato
sack wearing version from Part 2 is here
as well these are not superficial
changes either as each version of Jason
have a slightly different skill set in
the early beta the burlap sack version
of Jason had significantly reduced
movement in water whereas part 7 Jason
is quicker in water but can't store on
lumps these little nuances mean each
gift and require
different playstyles just let all the
campers let's look at some of the
mechanics at work the counselors are
pretty much no match for Jason but they
do have defensive actions to help
survive locking doors and hiding maybe
the way you react first word claim but
keep an eye out for bear tracks during
the data the best place to put a trap
was just in front of the front door so a
Jason barred you then you have a little
extra time to ask it before you recover
randomly scattered throughout each level
are items you need to get away the cab
for instance requires a new battery and
gasoline petrol that you prefer once
these are located is possible to fix the
vehicle and the schedule your life what
it's not as simple as turning a key in
flooring it no a mini game begins when
you start to fix each element of the
vehicle with any failures notifying gsyn
of your acts the pressure really adds to
your heart rate and this single mechanic
nothing not on intended it vital to
feeling the dread The [ __ ] drives to
achieve this also brings back the
counselor stats from earlier if you've
chosen a character with high levels of
intelligence and make sure you are the
one under the foot of the car it would
not be a Friday the 13th title without
unnecessarily grotesque waste to slay
innocent young people yes and is given
numerous ways to destroy his enemies
which are seemingly in three key areas
unarmed kills like crushing someone's
head or stomping them to death weapon
kills like chopping off limbs and even
environmental kills like throwing
victims through glass windows or even
more subtle things like hanging a
counselor on a court hook don't worry if
you're too busy running for your life to
witness GS and brutally manhandling your
friends at the end of each round the
highlight reel will play showing moments
from the gaming relive the torture
together that reminds me
never invite Jason round for breakfast
he's a serial killer sorry about that
the developers have also gone on record
to say almost all of Jason's iconic
murders from the film will be in the
game if the right opportunity occurs
every aspect of the games Maps reference
into film seamlessly the kills the
costumes the characters the locations
are all painstakingly recreated but it
detail you don't notice right away that
have a greatest East director if you've
seen Friday the 13th a new beginning you
can spot Tommy's raincoat hanging on the
wall there's also the teddy bear used by
Ted from the final chapter
Jason's original hockey mask is also
present on the desk in fact there are so
many nods and winks to the films that I
think I'll come back and create an
Easter Egg video G my special special
boy a single-player campaign has been
confirmed for the game but secret
sources claim it will be added both
launched in a free DLC pack and others
suggest it will come on disc from day
one either way it's definitely coming
your way a non-competitive outlet is a
welcome addition the soundtrack has been
composed in part by the legend that is
Harry Manfredini who is responsible for
creating the iconic sounds from the film
[Music]
Kane Hodder returns to mark up the live
actions of Jason and Tom Savini the man
behind the special effects of makeup in
the series returns to both I'll only be
able to remember him a sex machine in
front of killed dog
[Music]
it has been confirmed that we can indeed
kill Jason in the game Olga will not be
easy so maybe it's time to go back and
watch the films again to check for the
best technique what would you say the
better release date could be for a game
called Friday they're surfing on Friday
the 26th of May of course available on
ps4 steam and Xbox one are you picking
it up please let me know your thoughts
below I'm Adam from PlayStation granade
if you haven't subscribed to the channel
yet then come and join our dysfunctional
family I'll see you next time